aujourd'hui nous avons un président de
la république fraîchement sortis des
urnes qui va imprimer une nouvelle
vision de la société à laquelle je crois
en tout cas moi homme de gauche je
souhaite apporter au parlement au sénat
mme quelques correctifs
je crois que avec mon expérience de
président du daf à qui fédère 40
associations familiales en martinique
je suis en congé de la présidence pour
la campagne mais j'ai pu acquérir une
vraie vision la société martiniquaise
pascal udaf nous maîtrisons le fait que
c'est la politique familiale qui va
permettre d'améliorer la société de main
et lui conserver un visage humain un
caractère social il faut qu'il y ait des
hommes un peu de ma formation de mon
profil qui représente de manière
pragmatique efficace
effectivement le pays ainsi que des
propositions concertées pour parvenir à
ce redressement qui qui est absolument
urgent aujourd'hui pour notre pays